Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
Hello Walter. Good day Martin.
Today we are discussing
the steerings in the world. Yes, who is
ruling the world or is it the WEF
or the man in white?
Who's really ruling? Could also be the
man in black, you know? Good. Yes.
And it could be
be the man in gray because there's a
gray one as well.
Well, whoever it is
like we've said in the previous What's
Up Prof
where the question was asked as in the
days of Noah.
We mentioned there that
this will all be happening and going on
Mhm. without actually anybody realizing
or doing anything about it.
Yes, because it's a mystery.
The mystery of iniquity. It was already
working in Paul's day
and it is excelling itself at the
current time. Yeah. So, let's open with
a word of prayer and then we can get
into it.
Our heavenly Father
thank you for the blessing of being
here. Thank you for all that you do for
us and thank you that we can have this
discussion again. We ask that you
enlighten our minds
bless this discussion in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.
Now Martin, basically what we've done
here is
put a few videos together.
And actually, we should just sit and
watch and say nothing, huh? That's about
it because everybody at this stage, I
think that's been watching this
series
will have to do some study on their own
as well. And they should see start
seeing these things for themselves as
well by by now. Yes.
And the kings of the world will give
their power unto the beast.
That should be our cue throughout.
Everything else, whether it's called
who, whether it's called WEF
it's all window dressing. Mhm. Mhm.
That's it. Yes, because the puppets
change, but the puppeteer stays the
same. Exactly.
Yeah, and
if somebody by now don't know who the
puppeteer is Yeah. it's Satan.
Yes, and he has he has certain agents.
Yes.
So, the earthly agent obviously is the
man in white.
The Pope. Or the man in black.
The Or the black Pope or the man in
gray. The gray Pope. Yes.
Well, let's have a look.
I thought we would start with this
verse. Second Timothy 3:13, but evil men
and seducers shall wax worse and worse,
deceiving and being deceived.
It is the first time in history
that I think many many people have come
to the conclusion
that they cannot trust anything anymore.
Everything is a lie. That's true. Or
based on a lie.
And once you start down that slippery
road, then there is no holding back.
There is no end to which the lying won't
go.
Now, he was a murderer and a liar from
the beginning. Mhm.
So, his agents are also murderers and
liars.
And it is a sad state of affairs
when we have reached the point
where you can trust neither what a
government says nor what the media says
nor what many in the religious world are
saying. True. There is so much deceit
out there that we can clearly see that
the Bible when it says
that in the end even the elect may be
deceived. We can see it coming true and
how reliable the Bible is in that
statement. The Bible is absolutely
correct and anybody who
wants to continue denying
the fulfillment of prophecy misses the
point. Mhm. You know, it's the only book
that has this prophetic picture.
And the prophetic picture is written in
code.
But the code is supplied. Yes. Whereas
other prophetic writings are written in
code with no code supplied. So, you have
at best guesswork.
That's it and you can apply almost
anything to that that prophecy.
Depending on what your whim is.
So, it's actually a marvelous book and
you know, when I when I first discovered
Daniel chapter 7
and I realized what the Bible was saying
then I had to admit that it must be a
divinely inspired book.
Because I was trapped in every single
one of those systems. Yeah. Mhm.
So, evil men and seducers shall wax
worse and worse, deceiving and being
deceived.
Now, we've seen this face many times
before
and this organization, the World
Economic Forum
has much to say.
Now, if it weren't for the fact that
they have a bank account in harmony with
their clout
one could ignore them Mhm.
and continue making jokes about them
which many are doing, but somehow the
joke is on us. That's true. You see,
everybody wants to discard this great
reset and all of this
as conspiracy theory. Yes. But this is
not only been going on for the past two
or three years. This has been coming
from the early '80s. Yes, they've been
planning this for a very very long time.
And the role players are so interesting.
They all belong to these secret
societies
the secret little elite, their little
fan clubs
and their political leaders. Some of
them come and go, some of them stay
stuck behind the scenes
and seem to be ruling from behind the
scenes. You know, much like the Clintons
or the Obamas or any one of those.
They they come and they don't really go
because they still have their
organizations and their financial
backings and their this and their that
and their agendas.
And they seem to be above the law. No
matter what happens, lots of things come
out in the media, but nothing ever
happens.
So, it must be a very privileged
situation to be in.
And they can apply all the necessary
screws.
But the screws don't seem to apply to
them.
So, let's just have a look what this
gentleman has to say.
It will be a young world.
It will be a digital world. Now, who
could represent
such a world better?
So, new prime minister.
To represent also a new open
Canada.
I want to use this opportunity also to
thank our
Canadian constituency
which always has been a very loyal and
very much engaged constituency here at
the forum.
Meet Gabriel Boric, a leftist millennial
set to rule the southernmost country in
the world, Chile.
The youngest president ever to lead the
country, he's just 35 years old. But his
ambitions are rather bold. He's been
called the most left-wing president of
Chile since Salvador Allende, who was
overthrown in 1973.
Promises to raise the minimum wage in
Chile.
To reduce the cost of education and
health care.
To expand the country's social safety
net.
To fight climate change in the country
and to extend rights to native people as
well as gays and transgenders.
He is also the first president to win
with the largest number of votes in
Chilean history.
Bearded, tattooed, and rarely seen
wearing a tie.
Boric's victory was largely fueled by
Chile's youth. By millennials who were
fed up with decades of divisive
policies. And are said to have voted in
overwhelming numbers.
Australia has a new leader, Anthony
Albanese, a 59-year-old working-class
activist.
After 9 years in the opposition, this
center-left political organization is
back at the helm.
In his own words, Albanese was raised
with three great faiths, the Catholic
Church, the Labor Party, and the South
Sydney Football Club.
He was a progressive voice for LGBTQ+
rights, marching in Sydney Mardi Gras
parades, campaigning for the equal
rights of same-sex couples.
My message is I want to represent all
Australians. I want to unite the
country. There's been a lot of division
in recent times. That's one of my
criticisms of the current government is
that Scott Morrison looks for division
and difference rather than unity and
common purpose.
He campaigned on the promise of
providing financial assistance, a robust
social safety net, cutting down carbon
emissions, boosting renewable sources of
energy, offering discounts for electric
cars, and building community-owned solar
power projects.
Together, we can end the climate wars.
Together, we can take advantage of the
opportunity for Australia to be a
renewable energy superpower.
The right to privacy that forms the
basis of Roe is the same right to
privacy that protects the right to use
contraception
and the right to marry
the person you love
including a person of the same sex.
Overturning Roe opens the door to
restricting those rights.
Well, Martin, that is the smorgasbord
that is available to the world today.
And if I look at the ideologies that are
involved,
those ideologies are as far removed as
the East is from the West from the
morality of the Bible.
And yet we hear over and over again
their connection is with the Roman
Catholic Church.
That's it.
And what they are saying is not even
actually in harmony with the so-called
official position
of the church. of the church. Yes, but
that doesn't matter, of course, as long
as they all brandish the name.
So, where are we heading in society? Can
God's people
align themselves with this unity
direction when it is a unity on the road
to perdition?
True.
But also, if I may think of it, we've
mentioned before the pendulum.
For for a few years prior,
the pendulum was to the right and to a
little bit more morality and all of
this. Now all of the sudden it's
swinging to the left again. Yes.
So, this is
working up that conflict that you can
get the synthesis eventually.
And they all have the same buzzwords.
It's all climate change.
It's all renewal. It's all
inclusiveness.
Fraternity, no matter what.
Whether it is sin or whether it is not
sin, that's irrelevant.
Whether the Bible definitions of what
constitutes a family are applicable or
not doesn't seem to matter. And it
doesn't matter where in the world you
go, whether it is Africa,
whether it is South America,
whether it is North America, whether it
is Australia, whether it is China,
whether it is Europe, they're all on the
same bandwagon.
And the Bible says that just before the
coming of Christ, the world will be in
such a state
that it will be akin to what it was
before the flood, ripe for destruction.
God's people
cannot be associated with any any of
these things.
No. We have to rise above these things.
Unfortunately, we know that these
kingdoms will come to an end.
So, if we go to the Catholic Herald
of 19422,
climate healing by doing less one day a
week. Now, we put that in because it's a
recurring theme. Exactly. And
if all these leaders
shout that they will implement and do
everything they can for and against
climate change, Yes, and they all seem
to be Catholic, right?
That's it. What Where do they Where will
they get their plan of how to deal with
it? Yes. From?
From the man in white. Uh Obama recently
had a a talk in which he said that the
world
is in a sad place when people don't
trust their leaders anymore.
Well, you know, trust is earned. It's
not inherited with a job. That's it. And
if I listen to some of the speeches and
the coercion
and the tyrannical tactics that are
being uh applied to the populace,
then I'm afraid we have to seek refuge
in God.
So,
climate healing by doing less one day a
week.
This is a giant step the people of God
can take next weekend to benefit the
Earth's climate.
It's simple, easy, everyone is capable
of doing it, and best of all, it
involves doing less, not more.
I'm not a climate scientist, but I know
this, if 70 million US Catholics
embraced Pope Francis' encyclical
Laudato Si
on care of the creation and honored the
Lord's Day by following the third
commandment, we'd see a dramatic drop in
greenhouse gases.
Now, how many lies are
embodied in that simple statement? Well,
it's full of it. It's full of lies,
right?
So, firstly, he's not a scientist. We've
shown one scientist after the other
showing that they do not agree with the
the general picture. Of course, the
facts checkers will take that out, but
that in itself is an indication
that it that the opposite is true,
right?
And then
they don't even know the difference
between the third and the fourth
commandment, making it the same thing
because they've removed the second one.
And
they believe that somehow their false
third commandment is somehow affiliated
to greenhouse gases.
Now, Martin, who designed you to exhale
carbon dioxide? Yes, God did. God?
I think we should monitor that and put a
little monitor on you to see just how
much you produce and tax you on it. It's
coming if it's not already here.
Okay.
Prohibiting commercial vehicles on
Sundays would have a great impact. Is
there a good reason we can't walk, bike,
bus, or share rides to church?
No work except essential services. God
gave clear instructions. Where did he
say in the third commandment that you
weren't allowed to work on a Sunday?
Yeah. No way.
Because it's not
third commandment actually say?
Thou shalt not use the name of the Lord
in vain. Uh so, it seems to me that they
are really violating the third
commandment by twisting the third and
the fourth around
and saying what God never said in terms
of the fourth commandment.
So, God blessed the seventh day and
hallowed it because on it God rested. It
seems to me these people don't know the
difference between the first day and the
seventh day either. Correct. So, how
confused are these people? Totally. They
drink drank the wine of Babylon. They've
been imbibing in a tipsy tot.
Yes, this would disrupt the economy. So,
do we disrupt the economy, destroy our
common home?
And yes, we need to look at all human
activities that cause damage, but let's
start by honoring the Sabbath, creating
a powerful, inspiring beginning. I'd
love to do that except that they don't
like the Sabbath of the Lord. That's
true.
If the whole world were keeping the
fourth commandment, we wouldn't have any
of these problems.
Yeah, we wouldn't have any of this
nonsense and these lies wouldn't exist
in the first place. So, embracing the
Sabbath would help create a real time of
rest from this weary world, a time for
inward journeying, enabling us to more
easily break into music and become
joyful.
Martin, is it a good thing to be joyful
in a lie?
Unfortunately, there's nothing that can
do any good to a lie. No.
No. The Germans have a saying, Lügen
haben kurze Beine. Mhm.
Lies have short legs. Ah.
Mhm. Sooner or later things catch up
with them. So, basically, just by
putting this slide in, we can see how
deceived the world is and who the
deceiver is.
The one who sits on the throne dressed
in white
is the embodiment of the deception.
That's it. And all these leaders that
we've just seen in the previous video
are also going to want to implement this
letter out to see which has the same
wording. Which has the same wording and
the same implementation.
So, the WHO has decided to have an
emergency meeting.
Occasion the breakout of a new epidemic.
The World Health Organization is
convening a group of leading experts for
an emergency meeting to discuss the
ongoing monkeypox epidemic.
Martin
we've moved from one epidemic to another
and there are many sources which say
that the outcome of the first one is the
second one because it's built into the
program.
Now, be that as it may, seeing that they
are such experts in distorting the truth
the one wonders whether one can believe
anything that comes out of their mouth.
So, who in the WHO is actually
believable?
It's crazy at this stage because you've
got so much evidence on the one side
that
of the previous pandemic that
just doesn't add up.
Yes, so according to the paper, the
number of infected with monkeypox in
Great Britain has doubled and that was
confirmed by the Minister of Health
stating that there are 11 new cases of
infection. You know, even if there were
just two, they would have the same hype.
That's it.
So, the first patient to get monkeypox
on May the 7th traveled to Nigeria where
he's believed to be infected
before returning to England. There are
currently seven confirmed cases in
Britain.
Monkeypox which has been reported mainly
in the West and Central Africa so far is
a rare viral infection similar to
smallpox although in a milder form.
Now
they're very adamant as to what it is,
what causes this and how it is brought
about but no virus has ever ever been
isolated. Never.
So, it was registered this virus in the
DRC in the 1970s and the number of cases
in West Africa has increased in the past
decade
and the symptoms again fever, headache,
rash, etc.
So, according to the data on the website
of the World Health Organization, the
mortality from monkeypox was between 0
and 11% and lately it has varied between
3 and 6%.
I'm amazed at how accurate they are with
their percentages when there are 11
cases, none of whom have died.
It's amazing. Yes, I don't know how
these new statistics work but they're
brilliant.
The you see so you can have
wonderful percentages but the scale of
what you're comparing it on can be two.
It's ridiculous. Yeah.
It's ridiculous. So, basically what is
this Martin
this is fear-mongering.
And I think the public is slowly getting
very tired of this fear-mongering.
And then we have another genius who
seems to know exactly when what will
happen. Perhaps he should go into
inspired writing
rather than
in Microsoft activities.
Anyway, Microsoft founder Bill Gates
warns of bioterrorist attacks and urges
world leaders to use germ games to
prepare in interview with Jeremy Hunt.
So, the founder of Microsoft has warned
of bio- bioterrorist attacks and has
urged world leaders to use germ games to
prepare for them.
He said governments must get ready for
future pandemics and smallpox terror
attacks by investing billions in
research and development. I wonder who's
supposed to get that money.
And during a sit-down interview with the
chair of the Health Select Committee,
Jeremy Hunt, for the Think Tech Policy
Exchange, Mr. Gates suggested germ games
could be used to practice how to respond
to such events. He also called for the
formation of a new billion-dollar World
Health Organization Pandemic Task Force.
It'll take probably about a billion a
year for a pandemic task force at the
WHO level
which is doing the surveillance and
actually doing what I call germ games
where you practice.
He said. Yeah, this was already in
November 2021. This was in 2021 and he
was likening it to something like
smallpox.
Well, whether it's a small or whether
it's a monkey, it's a pox, right?
So, what happened to these so-called
simulations? Well, here's another
article from May
28, 2022.
International simulation in 2021
predicted the current monkeypox
outbreak. These people are all prophets.
Right?
The same with the previous pandemic. An
eerily accurate simulation exercise at
the Munich Security Conference in March
centered on a monkeypox outbreak
and had the rare and potentially deadly
hypothetical disease.
The Nuclear Threat Initiative, a
nonprofit founded by US media mogul Ted
Turner
and former Democratic Senator Sam Nunn.
Now, Ted Turner
was deeply involved in secret societies.
Gathered a panel of 19 experts including
government officials from the United
States and China, representatives from
the World Health Organization and the UN
researchers from the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and major pharma
companies to game out responses to a 12
Monkeys-like
bioterror attack.
So, this fictional scenario sponsored by
Facebook co-founder Dustin Moskovitz
and his Open Philanthropies nonprofit
hinged on the secret release of a
lab-enhanced monkeypox virus that
eventually killed 271 million people in
a worldwide 19-month pandemic.
The simulation's imaginary launch date
was May 15, 2022.
They're pretty accurate, right?
The same week that marked the real-world
start of the first international
outbreak of the viral disease more than
a year after the globalist group met.
Now
Gates also predicted that the next
pandemic would get everyone's attention.
Now they're claiming 271
million people
will die over a 19-month period. So,
they know exactly how long the pandemic
will last as well.
And
we're supposed to believe every word
that comes out of the mouth of these
gentlemen.
Well
maybe we will do good to to take heed
in knowing what's going to happen
because they seem to be
planning it ahead. Yes, now when we
watched that video of the new leader of
Chile didn't he use this sign?
So, it's interesting that many years ago
when we spoke about the affiliation of
these people
then everybody shouted conspiracy
theory.
But now it seems that the tables are
turned and the conspiracy theory is now
conspiracy fact in your backyard.
Exactly.
I'm so pleased that we can hear this
gentleman again because he has so many
things to say.
The future is not just happening.
The future is built by us
by a powerful community as
you here in this room.
We have the means
to improve the state of the world.
We're developing
through technology an ability for
consumers to measure their own carbon
footprint.
What does that mean? That's
where are they traveling? How are they
traveling? What are they eating? What
are they consuming on the platform? So,
individual carbon footprint tracker.
Stay tuned. If it comes 10 years from
now, we should have far far better
diagnostic technology. That is be able
to scale up every country within a month
to diagnose their entire population.
We're a little distracted right now so
getting the debate going
is happening slowly.
We need to accept that there will be
some pain in the process. The pace that
we need will
will open up for mistakes. It will open
up for shortages on energy. It will
create inflationary pressures and maybe
we need to start talking about that that
that pain is actually
worth it.
So, they used to call people who talked
about one world government, they used to
say, "Oh, it's a conspiracy." We would
always say, "No, it's in their mission
statement. They say it at every meeting.
That's what they're for." But
lack of sovereignty means lack of
freedom and it means lack of
responsiveness and it's completely
antithetical to everything our country
stands for. Yeah, privacy's not much of
a concern for these kind of people. So,
not only they want to track you for your
carbon footprint, the WHO has announced,
you know, they're forming a treaty and
it's going to be this treaty for the
next pandemic but in the next pandemic
it's not going to be a
Washington-based mandate on vaccines or
a Washington based social distancing or
mask. It's going to be an international
one and they actually want to track
everybody with a QRS code. You might not
be aware, but the abolition of democracy
by the global elites continues. On March
3rd, the EU Commission was authorized by
the council to renegotiate the treaty
with the World Health Organization on
behalf of the member states. Under the
guise of improving global pandemic
response, the plan is to allow the WHO
to seize executive governance governance
powers of the member states in the case
of a pandemic.
Well,
as Klaus Schwab said, they have the
power because they have this illustrious
group that is sitting in that particular
room
that is going to determine your carbon
footprint.
Mhm. You you were saying that we will
have to get a
measurement for individuals.
Absolutely. Some kind of monitor the
It's coming. Now, let's just get back to
basics. Who created humanity? God did.
God created humanity.
Did he create them with a capacity to
exhale carbon dioxide?
Yep.
So, whose responsibility ultimately is
it that humans exhale carbon dioxide?
It's God's. It's God's. So, that is a
built-in right to exhale.
So, do these people have the right to
put a monitor on me to find out how much
I exhale? No. And will they restrict my
exhaling at some stage? Yes. Perhaps
permanently. Yep. It's coming. Huh?
This will be the world of the future.
So, Martin, I'm so glad that I have a
Bible. Mhm. Because if these arrogant
individuals believe that they have the
right to interfere at every level of
your personal life and your personal
choices,
then they will have to deal with the one
who designed it so that you do have a
personal choice. Exactly. Now, if a if a
government or a church climbs onto that
bandwagon and becomes equally coercive,
then it becomes equally responsible for
its actions.
That is what they should start
realizing, especially the church.
Because God is not much longer going to
tolerate this.
Fortunately, the scriptures tell me
that.
And as our lead text said, they will wax
worse and worse. We have been
broadcasting this series for more than 2
years now
and can we honestly say that it's waxing
worse and worse? Definitely. Mhm? Oh,
for sure. For sure, right?
Anybody who doesn't see it must be an
ostrich. You see, that's the thing. Uh
if you don't realize all of this is
happening in its reality, these people
are saying now with the World Health
Organization
that they implement this treaty. We'll
be discussing that now in a little bit
more broader terms.
But it's worth the World
Economic Forum
who wants to rule the world by this one
world government. Just but who who are
they constantly pushing to the
forefront? Isn't it
Pope Francis and his agenda? All of
these answers to the Pope
in wanting to implement his Laudato Si.
Yes. So, the common factor
and the common little voice behind the
scenes remains that power,
that little horn power.
And the Bible clearly tells us that the
kings of the world will give their power
unto this organization.
And they have demonstrated not only
their willingness to do so,
but they were actually implementing it.
Take the
you that lady mentioned
that
energy crisis
and um inflation we have to get used to
this because it's worth it to go through
all of this.
It's worth it. Now, what is worth it? To
give up your rights. That seems to be
worth it.
Now,
the chameleon,
it can change its color, Mhm.
but it still remains a chameleon, right?
And if we look at the the track record
of the Roman Catholic Church and its
coercion
and its draconian methods that it used
in the Middle Ages,
we see exactly the same thing happening.
So, who's behind it? The same
That same spirit. Same.
So, how willing are the world
governments, Martin, to surrender their
sovereignty?
Well,
this is an important question. Because a
lot of people will be sitting around the
world saying, "Yeah, but they're just
talking. They're not implementing any of
this."
All right. Now, once you surrender your
sovereignty, surely the question must be
who do you surrender it to? Mhm.
So, now they're saying, "All right,
they're surrendering certain portions of
their authority to the World Health
Organization."
But who is the World Health Organization
responsible to?
See, they always work with front
organizations. Mhm. Mhm. That's it.
Exactly what it is.
And here is Joy News and it tells us
that Ramaphosa, who is the president of
South Africa, joins urgent call for the
WHO global pandemic treaty.
So, now you have government leaders
asking for the same thing.
In other words, they're begging for
their sovereignty to be curtailed. And
what this new treaty of the World Health
Organization entails is that they will
decide on how every country will
implement the restrictions and all of
that, not the country itself. So,
they've handed over their power. Mhm.
Who does the Bible say they're handing
it over to?
The beast. The beast. Mhm. All right.
So, the Bible says they're handing it
over to the beast. So, surely the World
Health Organization must be a
subdivision of the beast. That's it.
Together with the World Economic Forum.
Together with anybody else who climbs
onto this and bandwagon with their funny
little hand signs and their willingness
to curtail your personal freedoms,
right?
Mhm.
So, is he alone? Let's have a look.
President Cyril Ramaphosa joined 24
international leaders to endorse the
World Health Organization's
urgent call for a new international
pandemic treaty that will hand ultimate
control of the health care systems of
194 nations to unelected bureaucrats.
Now, Martin,
they hand over their power to these
unelected bureaucrats.
And they're they're using the health
arm. So, you need a lot of
fearmongering.
You need whatever pox you can conjure
up, whether it is a monkeypox,
which comes from Africa. Of course, the
monkeys in Asia don't seem to have it.
Only the monkeys in Africa seem to have
it. That's very convenient. But the
point I'm making
is
that there is a right arm
to this message, which happens to be a
health message.
And it's linked to all of these
organizations and they have power. They
have power to force you to do that which
you might not agree with.
So, Tata does a new international treaty
for pandemic preparedness and response.
The treaty gives the WHO the power to
unilaterally intervene in the affairs of
nations suspected of having a health
emergency
of possible concern to other nations,
including the power to declare an
international health emergency
nullifying the powers of nation states.
So, the World Health Organization
convened
during 22 to 28 May
at the United Nations headquarters in
Geneva, Switzerland to formalize the
measure. If the new international
pandemic treaty is ratified,
Ramaphosa will give the WHO jurisdiction
over the health care of private citizens
as well as seed SA sovereignty to the
World Health body. But not only he, all
the other world leaders as well.
So, let's have a look at who they are.
Here's another article from May 20,
"Multiple governments commit to signing
WHO pandemic treaty."
So, you have the Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom.
You have Zelenskyy, the president of the
Ukraine. Now, all of these people, are
they
elevated in the media? Mhm. Mhm. And
they all have certain images, right? The
whole time. They They've
full on in the news the whole time.
And you have the Prime Minister of
Norway and Portugal and Italy and
Romania and France and Germany and the
president of the European Council and
the Prime Minister of Greece and Spain
and the Netherlands and Chile and
Siberia and Croatia. You know, the list
goes on and on, whether you're talking
about Fiji and Thailand, Costa Rica,
Tunisia, New Zealand. So, Canada, the
United States, Australia, New Zealand
can be added to this list.
And India has just joined the list of
countries that supports giving the WHO
more powers.
Uh Martin, is this the kings of the
world? Definitely. And it seems to be
the whole world. And who are they giving
their power to? Let's ask that question
again, because who's really in charge?
Yeah. So, who's Is it the World Health
Organization? Is it the International
Monetary Fund?
Is it these kings?
They must be relinquishing their power
to someone.
And the Bible states who that person is
or system is. The Bible tells us who it
is, so anything else is a front.
Pushed in there for the sake of
convenience
based on nothing other than lies.
They know exactly what the percentage
death rate is with 11 people having
contracted disease, none of which have
died. Now, Martin, it seems as not only
humans are in the fray here.
Uh, methane is another problem.
And a British startup says we must now
introduce masks for cows
to limit their exhaling methane. Now,
who designed them to exhale methane,
Martin?
God.
Now, it's a criminal offense for the cow
to exhale methane.
So, something must be seriously done
about this. So, now every cow must wear
a mask.
At least I see that they're wearing the
mask on the nose. It will probably have
to be worn
dual way. Martin, do you think that a
cow produces methane only from the front
or should there be masks in other places
as well? It's going to become
quite ridiculous if it keep keeps on
like this. How ridiculous can you
become?
Can we ask that question? I think so.
Hm?
Wait.
At the risk of being banned.
You know what? I wonder what the facts
checkers will do.
I don't know how many episodes ago we
said logic stepped out of the the room.
There's not no logic left.
There's no logic whatsoever. So, when
all of this surveillance
and this monitoring of what people are
doing, when that all started
it was, of course, strictly a Chinese
issue.
But, uh, very early on we said this is
not going to remain a Chinese issue,
it's going to become an international
issue.
So, let's just see how far we are along
this road.
Is the European Union on its way to
becoming a surveillance society like
China?
The European digital identity. This
cheery introduction to the EU's upcoming
digital identity program tells citizens
that it will make their lives easier
while keeping them safer online.
It's already under attack in the
European Parliament is something that
would be ripe for government abuse. One
of its chief critics, European
Parliament member Christian Terheș was
born in communist Romania and has long
been warning of the EU's so-called
Chinafication. Clearly, we are
witnessing right now the Chinafication
of Europe.
Because we see what is happening in
China right now with the social credit
score, where the government is
monitoring and uh, surveilling all the
people from the beginning to end. How
voluntary is the European digital
identity wallet? But even more
important, how voluntary will it remain
in the future?
Because the European Union always comes
up with nice plans to eventually abuse
it to create more control. The EU's
COVID passport was supposed to be
temporary. Now, Brussels wants to extend
it until at least June of next year.
COVID passports have been used to
prevent the unvaccinated from crossing
borders, entering grocery stores, using
public transit, and even going to their
jobs. It's helped fuel violent
demonstrations, the likes of which
Europe hasn't seen for decades. Some in
Washington are urging Joe Biden to
establish digital identities for
Americans as a way of fighting identity
theft. There's also support in Congress.
Not only are digital IDs coming to
Europe, but in Italy, the cities of Rome
and Bologna have begun social credit
programs that reward citizens for
behavior that officials think will fight
climate change like using a bicycle
instead of a car. A social credit system
could be easily incorporated into a
digital identity.
You may not have to grab your wallet or
phone to pay when you go to a checkout
in future. That's because Mastercard has
rolled out a new way of paying a bill,
and it's with your face. Ajay Bhalla is
president of cyber and intelligence at
Mastercard. It's a
cool new technology
which allows consumers to pay
with a smile, their face, or just wave.
But not everyone agrees we should share
our biometric data.
Mastercard said their first pilot would
launch this week in Brazil with the
PayFace app. This is what makes the
difference
between a tyranny and democracy.
When you know everything about what your
government does, that's democracy.
When the government knows everything
about you, that is tyranny.
I think he has a point. I agree with
him. You agree with him?
Martin, you're way too conservative.
I think the Bible also agrees with this.
You should be on the barricades
or marching with those millions of
people cheering the new heroes
who want to give their power unto the
beast. Shouldn't you be doing that?
That's what the majority will be doing.
Well, Martin, it seems to me that
humanity is going to be forced to make a
choice.
We've been saying
that a choice is coming. I I just want
to bring You say that they're going to
be forced, but I must tell you that I
think that there's a majority of
humanity that wants to go ahead and join
this wants this. Yes, I I know they want
that, and they will force anyone who
doesn't want to go along with it.
And uh,
that will eventually be the minority.
Now, how do you make sure
that this majority grows?
All you have to do is make it popular by
putting a certain amount of money into a
so-called wallet.
That's it. E-wallets.
And just give some incentives
and anybody who doesn't want to go along
with it becomes an enemy of the state.
There was a movie like that once, Enemy
of the State, and we are seeing it
enacted before our very eyes.
Fortunately
if you study the Bible, you know what
the outcome is going to be. That's the
thing. That was That's what will keep
you sane.
Otherwise, if you don't want to go along
with this, but you don't know the
biblical prophecy on these things,
you'll start getting into depression.
So, how important is it that we
constantly remember
that there is a moral thread running
through this?
And that moral thread is linked to
Sunday legislation. That's it.
And why? Because it has to do with the
authority of God. That's it.
And in how far do you want to usurp the
authority of God
and the sovereignty of God?
Now, this article is somewhat older, it
comes from 2021, but it does ask the
question
are social credit systems coming to the
West?
And they state that the social credit
systems that operate in China are not
unpopular with the Chinese.
So, it seems as if the people actually
like them.
You see, you remember there's a there's
a
um, statement in the spirit of prophecy
that says
by popular demand
these things will be implemented.
Yes. Now
it is it is very strange to me that by
popular demand you will want to be
surveilled.
Well, that is the conclusion you will
come to if you read the research. The
Chinese social credit system began not
in government, but in the commercial
sector.
As China transformed from a planned
economy to a market economy, the lending
industry required some guarantee that
loans would be repaid.
The idea was to create a sincerity
culture that rewarded those who paid
their loans or traded goods.
Now, in the West, here we are again
with people who mistrust each other
wishing to enact some kind of sincerity
system for social cohesion
in an attempt to protect themselves from
their less trustworthy peers. Perhaps we
should be
careful what we wish for.
See, everything can be packaged in a
nice package.
But, uh, the end thereof is what we have
to look out for.
So, now in Germany
they've just introduced the first bakery
chain that only accepts electronic means
of payment. So, we seem to be going
towards the electronic banking system,
which is all predicted in the Bible.
That's it.
Now, Martin when it comes to these
elites that want to implement their
ideas and force them upon humanity, how
far are they willing to go?
Well, for them it they will go as far as
it is necessary even if it means
collateral damage. Uh-huh. So, they
don't care about the collateral damage
because they seem to be above it, right?
Yeah.
So, let's just listen to what uh Mr.
Harari has to say on the issue. I know
we've had him a number of times,
but he's particularly informative in
terms of his ideas. Yes, because you
must remember he's the advisor for our
Schwab who is the World Economic Forum.
So, these are all integrated. Yes.
Let's hear what he has to say.
70,000 years ago, our ancestors were
insignificant animals. The most
important thing to know about
prehistoric humans is that they were
unimportant. Their impact on the world
was not much greater than that of
jellyfish or fireflies or woodpeckers.
There is a a distinct possibility that
computers will outperform us in most
tasks and will make humans redundant.
And then the big political and economic
question of the 21st century will be
what do we need humans for or at least
what do we need so many humans for? Do
you have an answer in the book?
Um at present the best guess we have is
uh keep them happy with drugs and
computer games.
But this doesn't sound like a very
appealing future. One possibility is
this creation of a new massive class of
useless people. Another possibility is
the division of humankind into different
biological castes with the rich being
upgraded into virtual gods and the poor
being degraded to this level of of of
useless useless people. Now, humans are
developing
even bigger powers than ever before. We
are really acquiring divine powers of
creation and destruction. We are really
upgrading humans into gods.
Martin, I will refrain from a value
judgment in terms of the gentleman's
ideas.
Suffice to say that they are absolutely
in contradiction to what the Bible has
to say.
But he's in agreement
with the scientific narrative.
Correct. But he totally ignores the
biblical narrative. 70,000 years ago, we
were, you know, not much better than
than
jellyfish, yes. That is so contrary to
what the scriptures say.
Man was created a noble being
with a high moral stature.
But he fell and ended up with this
gentleman is
thinking that they are gods
and the rest are useless eaters.
Now, uh is it really so that we were so
primitive or were we noble created in
the image of God?
That's it. We were created in the image
of God, perfect beings. Yes. If you had
to stand opposite Adam
and it had to look up to this tall
well-proportioned
brilliant individual,
it feel like a a roach compared to what
came out of the hands of God, right?
So, Martin, God is wanting to reinstate
humanity
and to restore the lost image.
These people are trying to degrade
humanity
and turn them into caste systems where
you have a divine elite
Mhm. and a That's it. That is an
arrogance beyond computation. But isn't
that also
a Catholic a um a Roman Catholic
hierarchy
thinking?
Completely so because in terms of the
the Catholic hierarchy,
they wield the spiritual sword
which is over and above the political
sword.
So, they are in control of everything.
And to be subject to the Roman Pontiff
is absolutely necessary for salvation.
It's one of their statements which they
cannot retract.
So, how far do they want to go? Well,
here's an article in The Guardian the
31st of May 2022.
Uh
Tamagotchi kids, could the future of
parenthood be having virtual children in
the metaverse?
So, AI will make it possible to have
responsive programmable and highly
realistic children in the metaverse.
According to an expert on artificial
intelligence, would-be parents would
soon be able to opt for cheap and
cuddlable digital offspring.
Age yet to be born, though it won't be
long.
Is she pregnant? No. Well, I don't know.
That's not the point. What's the point?
That some people might decide never to
be pregnant ever again. That's already
happens, doesn't it? True.
For loads of reasons including concerns
about the environment, overpopulation,
the rising cost of bringing up children.
So, who is this Catriona Campbell then?
One of the UK's leading authorities on
artificial intelligence. She has a new
book called AI by Design, a plan for
living with artificial intelligence.
So, what does she say in it? That within
50 years technology will advance to such
an extent that babies will exist in the
metaverse or indistinct from those in
the real world. So, Martin, you will
have digitized children. And not
overpopulate the earth. And you can you
can program them.
I just want to digress here a little
bit. Do you remember this Harari? He
just mentioned in 2015 when asked how
what will you do with this useless
class? Keep them busy with drugs
and games.
And here is becoming a reality.
Now, metaverse is already being used in
in game playing. So, you get these
glasses,
then you perform in a in a game, a ball
game or any game. Everything is virtual
reality. There's no reality. There's
even meetings. Everything that a whole
world exists in the metaverse. Now,
here's an irony. If you take the movie
The Matrix,
it implies
that we are in a matrix and that the
creator has actually put us into a
virtual world and that nothing is real,
right?
That's it. But in actual fact, when you
look at what they are doing, they are
doing exactly what they accused God of.
Yes. Isn't that right? 100%. They are
creating this meta reality.
And this meta reality robs you of your
individuality,
your freedom of choice and being a free
agent in God.
So, basically what what the world has to
choose between
is a reality that is fully controlled
from the top down in terms of every
aspect of your life including your
morality
or the freedom that God gave you.
And Jesus Christ was prepared, who is
the creator because by him were all
things created. He was prepared to die
for your freedom of choice.
There was no coercion with him.
This system is replete with coercion.
We have two world systems. We have two
worldviews. We have two rulers.
One
who grants you freedom of choice
but says that if you want to be part of
his kingdom, then you have to endorse
his morality and his law.
Here you have another system
which is totally devoid of morality
which has anything goes as long as you
have solidarity
which have laws which contradict the
very basis of biblical morality.
And people will have to make a choice.
And the choice won't be easy because the
problem is if you go against this,
you're not going to be popular and it's
not going to be easy. Now, that's where
you're going to have to grab hold of the
Well, by the grace of God, Martin, by
the grace of God, I would rather die
than be part of this system.
And therefore, my only hope is that God
will end this system and he has promised
that he will end this system. And the
whole refuge of lies will be swept away.
And my prayer is that it will come
sooner
than later.
God has created us in his image.
And his image has a moral
ambiance that was demonstrated in the
life of Jesus Christ to humanity.
And it changed people.
If you look at the story of John, one of
the sons of thunder, what he became.
And yet, he never gave up his
individuality.
He never gave up his freedom of choice,
and he became an individual reflecting
the image of God.
May we make similar choices. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, the world is heading
on a speed train towards perdition.
And the world and the world leaders and
the churches seem to be in corrupt
harmony.
Help us to rise above it
and to cling to a morality
that has a divine origin. I pray in
Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.